new details on Megan Markel and Prince
Harry's moved to LA but I heard that
helps you understand what did it come to
that I would step my family back
bittersweet and stronger are two of the
words being used to describe the
couple's post royal life in California a
source tells ET that it's a bit ironic
because one thing that made Megan
unhappy about living in the UK was that
she felt isolated and missed her friends
and now that she's back in the US which
is what she wanted she's still isolated
and can't see her friends due to the
corona virus pandemic well I've spoken
to sources close to the saucers who say
that they are very strictly following
those guidelines and that does extend to
not seeing anyone outside of their
immediate families so my understanding
is that they've been keeping in touch um
through you know through social media
not actually seeing each other in person
which must be incredibly hard to Megan
being so close to her mother according
to our source one of Megan in Harry's
quote happiest times was when they first
got to Canada no one knew they were
there and they could hang out with
friends go hiking and play outside with
Archie I never thought my life would be
that awesome
but even though Megan and Harry's moved
to the States hasn't been what they
originally had in mind our source says
they're trying to make the most of it
and it's actually been great for them as
a couple quote their relationship is
stronger than ever the source says that
not having as many distractions and
commitments has been a blessing
according to our source the pair is
using this time to be really thoughtful
and strategic about the type of work and
projects they want to be involved in
this gives them ample opportunity to
really put all of their efforts and all
of their focus into the black lives
matters campaign I'm told this is really
where they want to focus their energy
and make a difference they're speaking
to community leaders and from a number
of different organizations and charities
and told this is something they want to
keep private at the moment while they
work out what they can do and how they
can help as for what the suspect is will
do once quarantine is over
according to our source they know they
can't fly under the radar so they're
doing everything they can to have more
control over what they use their
spotlight and platform for the source
ads that Megan tends to overthink
everything now because she's so used to
being kicked apart and criticized for
everything inevitably when she speaks
publicly Megan comes under fire she does
seem to be criticized for whatever she's
saying she knows it's going to happen
it's very much on the online community
and it's really not something that the
couple engage with they they dismiss it
and they move on
[Music]